Hello everyone and welcome to the lange
focus channel.
Today I'm going to talk about a question
that I've been getting quite a lot
recently and that is what kind of job
can I do with my foreign language skills
or what kind of job should I do if I'm
interested in foreign languages?
Now this is a question that I respect
because I've witnessed a lot of people
investing years of their life into
studying a language kind of with the
assumption that it would naturally
improve their career or give them new
opportunities,
but without having a plan for how they
would use that language,
they didn't really benefit from it and
ended up being quite frustrated.
So young people who are asking this
question early on,
I think you are thinking about things
the right way,
but the answer to this question depends
on just how you imagine your life in the
future and how far you really want to go
with your language study.
Now,
some jobs are specifically language
related.
Other jobs are not specifically language
related,
but a foreign language could be an asset
and for other jobs it's not really
necessary at all,
but it might be useful for your overall
lifestyle.
I'm going to talk about those three
types of situations.
So first up are jobs that are
specifically language related.
For these jobs,
you need to have some expertise in the
language.
You need to have a deep understanding of
the language.
So the first kind of job is to teach a
language.
Here in Japan,
I know a lot of people who teach
English.
I also know people who teach other
languages like French or Spanish.
Now,
even if you don't have a lot of
qualifications,
there are some opportunities to teach
your language,
especially if it's a major global
language and especially if it's English,
but the more qualifications that you
have,
then of course the better opportunities
you get and the higher pay you can get,
the better positions you can find.
Now if you want to study a foreign
language that's not your native language
and then teach that language,
then you're looking at a situation where
you really need to get some expertise.
You really need to get qualifications.
You should get like a masters degree or
maybe a phd or qualifications that show
that you know that language very well at
an academic level,
at a deep level of not just a
conversational level.
That's if you're going to teach a
language that's not your native
language.
Now another type of job that is language
specific is becoming a translator or an
interpreter.
Now the difference between those,
just to clarify a translator is somebody
who translates texts.
They translate written materials from
one language to another,
but an interpreter as somebody who
translates speech that translate the
things people are saying live in real
time as they are speaking.
Now,
being a translator or an interpreter
requires you to have a very deep
understanding of that language because
there's really no room for error or
misunderstanding.
You have to translate sometimes very
important information and mistakes could
be a big problem.
So you need to have very good almost
native level skills,
especially for if you're interpreting in
real time.
But also you need to learn the skills of
translation or interpreting.
Those are separate skills that you need
to learn on top of knowing the language.
So for these jobs that are specifically
language related,
there's really no room for language
dabblers.
You really need to have a comprehensive
understanding of that language and you
have to be able to show that you can use
that language at almost a native level.
Next up are jobs that are not
specifically language related.
They are basically focused on another
skill that you need.
But the language is an additional asset.
The first kind of job is one that
requires some technical expertise,
but having a language on top of that,
we'll give you some extra opportunities.
So an example that I've heard is from an
engineer.
His company sells some sort of machines
to companies around the world and they
send this engineer to those companies so
he can teach people how to use those
machines in their factory so he learns
foreign languages so that he can do
that.
I believe this guy in particular was
working in Indonesia,
so he learned Indonesian to be able to
teach those people in their native
language.
Another example,
career,
his business with a regional focus.
For example,
maybe you get a commerce degree or you
get a master's of business
administration,
an Mba,
but also you have some language skills
and maybe you work for a company that
does business in that region or does
business with companies in that region.
Another example career is the foreign
service.
Being a diplomat,
being someone who works at your
country's embassies abroad.
When you work in the foreign service,
I think that often involves some kind of
language training before you are sent
abroad,
but knowing some languages in advanced
before you apply is probably a big
asset.
Another example is being a tour guide.
Now a tour guides.
Main focus is not the language,
it's the history and it's the
anthropology and all of those sorts of
things,
but having a language that they can
explain things in that will help them
have other opportunities.
So maybe you might specialize in
tourists from Japan,
you learn Japanese,
you can be a tour guide for Japanese
tourists depending on where you live.
Another option might be to do some other
job in the tourism industry or open a
business in the tourism industry.
If you live on Bailey island in
Indonesia,
then you would be crazy not to learn
English and Japanese and maybe some
other languages that are common amongst
tourists.
Another career as being a cabin
attended.
Now their main focus is on safety
training on a emergency response and
that kind of thing.
But knowing a language that's an
additional asset,
probably they need to know English in
most cases,
but they also need to know the language
of the country they're working in or of
the destination that they often fly too.
Maybe they don't need to know it
fluently,
but knowing some of that language will
help them deal with the passengers on
the plan.
So if you live in Los Angeles and you
often fly to Asia than knowing Japanese
or Korean or mandarin or another
language like that would probably be a
big asset.
Now all of these jobs I just talked
about,
they're focused on another important
skill,
so they're not focused on language.
So you don't need a specific language
qualification in most cases,
but you need to be able to demonstrate
that you can use that language on the
job.
That's the most important thing.
The third type of job I want to mention
is one that doesn't really have any
language requirement,
but learning that language would be
useful for your off time and for your
overall lifestyle.
So let's say that you live in Singapore
and your company does business in
English,
then you don't have to learn any other
language.
People in Singapore speak English,
but nearby as Malaysia and Indonesia.
So let's say you want to travel there on
your off time.
Learning molay or learning Indonesian
would be very useful in that situation.
So think about the kind of lifestyle
that you want to have and think about
how language is fit in with that.
Let's say that you want to live the
corporate expat lifestyle and some place
like Hong Kong.
Then you can study Cantonese while you
get your finance degree or you get your
mba or whatever.
If you want to be a programmer and you
can program from your laptop anywhere in
the world,
then think about what country you would
like to live in and learn the language
of that country.
If you're an avid traveler and you love
the idea of living in different
countries all the time,
then you can learn how to do businesses
on the Internet and you can learn the
language of whatever countries that you
want to spend an extended period of time
then or if you want to learn a foreign
language and you want to someday reach
to an expert level and be able to teach
that language,
then plan ahead for that.
Maybe go for your master's degree,
your phd tried to really get a deep
understanding and overall knowledge of
that language.
So these are just my thoughts on that
based on things that I know and things
that I've heard.
But a lot of the viewers have different
perspectives.
Some of you probably have jobs that
involve foreign languages,
so we want to know what you think.
If you have any other ideas or any
questions about this topic,
leave them down below.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.